let's try to get a better intuition of
the chain rule and in the process we'll
get a better intuition of how it applies
to implicit differentiation or vice
versa so let's say and i'm going to get
out of the world of x's and y's and f of
x's for a second just so that you see
that those are just letters and there's
nothing special about them and i think
sometimes it helps develop the intuition
so let's say that
a
is equal to
b
squared
and that
b
is equal to
the sine
of c
and my question to you is
what is the derivative of a
with respect to
c
what is the derivative of a with respect
to c
well we have a defined in terms of b so
it's not like we can just you know take
the derivative i mean how do we do that
well that's where the chain rule comes
in and the chain rule just tells us that
the derivative of a
with respect to c is equal to the
derivative of a
with respect to b
times the derivative of b with respect
to c and you shouldn't really this you
don't even have to memorize this this is
just we're just multiplying two
fractions where the denominator in the
first one is the same as the numerator
and the second one so if you were to
multiply fractions they would cancel out
right or you would you know if you were
to actually multiply these fractions out
you'd get da
times db on the numerator and the
denominator you would get
da sorry db
times dc in the numerator and then these
would cancel out and then you're back
with da over dc
so there's nothing fancy really about
the chain rule when you actually view
them for what they are they're fractions
but the the the values in the numerator
and the denominator they are these
differentials these infinitely small
changes
in these variables but anyway so
change the chain rule tells us change of
a with respect to c is equal to the
change of a with respect to b
times the change of b with respect to c
and these are pretty easy to calculate
based on the information that i've just
given you what is the change of a with
respect to b the derivative of a with
respect to b
well that's pretty straightforward right
derivative of a
with respect to b is equal to 2b
so this is 2b
and what's the derivative of b with
respect to c
derivative of b with respect to c
well that's equal to cosine of c
cosine of c
and so we're done the derivative of a
the derivative of a
with respect to c
is equal to
this which is this 2b
the derivative of a with respect to b
times the derivative of b with respect
to c so times
cosine
of c
and then if you don't like it in this
format if you don't like the derivative
of a with respect to c
being dependent or being a function of
both b and c you can just substitute for
b because b is also a function of c so
let's do that so the derivative of a
with respect to c is equal to 2 b but
what's b
b is just sine of c
so 2
the substitute sine of c for b
sine of c
and then we have the remainder right
this
is this
and then times cosine of c
cosine of c and that's just that and
we're done
and i want to now try to make the
connection between this and the the kind
of um
i don't want to say well you know kind
of the the plain english way i talked
about doing the chain rule before so all
of the chain rule problems that i think
i've done so far it would have had a
explicitly defined in terms of c but
you're saying oh but then you know that
i said the outside of the inside and et
cetera and we can do that we can make a
explicitly defined in terms of c and how
do we do that we can substitute before
we even take the derivative so we can
substitute this for here
and we get what
a
is equal to
b squared b is sine of c so it's sine
sine of c
squared
and now we could take the derivative of
a with respect to c using the chain rule
and this is the more traditional way
that i showed it but maybe it gave you
more intuition it probably gave you more
intuition of how to actually do the
problem but it probably gave you less
intuition of how it applies to the chain
rule so hopefully this will connect
everything together so the derivative of
a
with respect to
c is equal to let's take the you know i
think sometimes i i said that i like to
take the derivative of the inside and
then multiply that times the derivative
of the outside but we could do it in
either order so let's take the
derivative of the outside so what's the
derivative of the outside sine of c
squared well it's 2 sine of c
2 sine of c
times the derivative of the inside
derivative inside is cosine of c
cosine of c
we'll see the phone is ringing
i'm not going to answer it
and so what we ended up with the exact
same result and it makes sense because
when i say the derivative of the outside
when i take the derivative of sine c
squared and i get 2 sine of c i'm really
just taking the derivative of a with
respect to b right because the
derivative of a with respect to b is 2b
or 2 sine of c and then when i take the
derivative of the inside i'm really
taking the derivative of b with respect
to c so hopefully that gives you a
little intuition so now let's take that
intuition and and tackle some implicit
differentiation problems
and if you think about this kind of was
an impulse implicit differentiation
problem
so let's say i have i want to take the
derivative
the derivative with respect to x of
y squared
x to the third
and some of you all might know how to
mechanically do this
you know you just well i won't go into
the mechanics because the whole point of
this video is intuition and maybe you
have the intuition which case you might
not have to watch this video but let me
give you the intuition and i think the
best way to give the intuition is to
actually do some variable substitution
let's read of let's define
a is equal to y squared and b
is equal to x to the third
right then this is the same thing and i
just made these definitely this could
have been any letters this is the same
thing
as the derivative with respect to x
of a
times b
right
and what does the chain rule tell us
well actually we can just do the product
rule here so let's do the product rule
so we're taking the derivative with
respect to x of a times b
so let's do that this is just the
product rule so it's the derivative of a
with respect to x derivative of a with
respect to x times b
plus the derivative of b with respect to
x
derivative of b with respect to x times
a
that's just the product rule but what's
the derivative of a with respect to x
and what's the derivative of b with
respect to x
so the derivative of a with respect to x
and this is where
we we we get into the chain rule
the derivative of a with respect to x
is equal to
the derivative of a with respect to y
times the derivative of y with respect
to x right this is just the chain rule
look these d y d in the denominator and
the numerator they'll cancel out
so this is just the chain rule and what
is this what's the derivative of a with
respect to y well a is equal to y
squared so that is equal to 2
y
times the derivative of y with respect
to x well we haven't explicitly defined
y in terms of x so we're just going to
have to leave it like that so times
d y
d x
so this right here the derivative of a
with respect to x is just that
and what's the derivative of b with
respect to x well here b is explicitly
defined in terms of x so this is pretty
straightforward this is
there's no chain rule application here
so that is just going to be 3x squared
and so what's our final answer
the final answer is the derivative of
with respect to x of y squared x to the
third
is equal to derivative of
a with respect to x or you could view
that as the derivative of y squared with
respect to x
which is
y
d y
dx
right this is just you could say this is
the derivative of a with respect to x or
the derivative of y squared with respect
to x and this is just from the chain
rule right this was the chain rule 2y
times dydx and then times b
well what's b b is x third x to the
third times x to the third
plus
the derivative of b with respect to x
well that's 3
x squared times a a is just y squared
so hopefully that gave you the intuition
and it made it a little bit clearer of
why implicit differentiation you're
really just applying the chain rule and
then you know just the way i've been
doing in all the problems without going
through all of this message to so it
isn't that hard of a problem is you
could just do it
straight up you could say okay this is
the product rule it's the derivative of
the first expression
times the second expression plus the
derivative of the second expression
times the first what's the derivative of
this first expression y squared what's
the derivative of that expression with
respect to y
times the derivative of y with respect
to x and it's only because we're taking
the derivative with respect to x
times the second expression x to the
third
plus the derivative of the second
expression with respect to x
three x squared
times the first expression
y squared well anyway i'm at my time
limit hopefully that helped a little bit
and didn't confuse things and
let me know if you want me to do even
more videos on this see you soon